he is one of our favorite guests the
actor o'shea jackson jr back here on the
rich eisen show how are you sir
i'm good man you know i'm out here
chilling i uh
i was in virginia for six months doing
uh a show for
kevin durant and apple on cbs by the
name of swagger
so it made me really happy to see
uh to see the old boss lose to the
lakers the other night
so do you do you send do you send the
old boss
any texts or we're not we don't do that
because they're it's still there's still
a
a competition that you don't want to
broach here
okay i think the i think the last thing
that i
said to him was lakers in five and then
he just stopped uh answering me
[Laughter]
well i guess or or maybe he's just wary
of uh texting with celebrities these
days because he just doesn't know what
might actually come out
you know what i mean yeah thanks thanks
mike thanks mike appreciate that buddy
you might be a little gun shy when he's
doing all that uh all right so i figured
if you wouldn't mind to be our rich
eisen show wrestlemania 37 correspondent
over the weekend the if you the
wrestlemania 37 rich eisen show
reviewer if you don't mind um
what did you what did you like about
wrestlemania 37 this weekend
um uh well wrestlemania 37 it definitely
will be
one of those wrestlemanias that i have
you know logged into my head for
quite some time and a lot of it has to
do with
uh the crowd you don't know what you
have until it's gone
and man you know just to see wrestling
with a large crowd again getting
reactions hearing the noise
and in real time it's uh it was a
special thing
uh and i feel like every superstar out
there
last night brought it and yes there were
the big title matches
uh bianca bellaire pretty much stole the
show she is the
the story we've all been following uh
also shout out to ria ripley
they are going to be the two women
leading the charge in the new wrestling
year
um but i think the ones that really
stood out
were the matches that weren't for a
title you know
uh the kevin owens sami zayn was uh one
of the one of the best
wrestling matches that i've seen you
know it didn't go outside the ring for
too long
everything was inside uh two guys
showing that they can wrestle
and they're best friends and you know
they're their best friends so they've
they've been together for a while
they're
they got a little turmoil now but
they've been together for a while
they know how to put on a show with each
other
and that's exactly what we got you know
when you're on the card at wrestlemania
you better bring it and i feel like
everyone brought it this year
hey o'shea this is tj what up man
so um i agree with you about kevin and
sammy those two have probably wrestled
each other about 300 times over the last
20 years so it had to be just like
working with a partner that you're so
familiar with that
it made it easy um i want to talk to you
about the celebrity match though right
off the top the
bad bunny and damien priest getting that
dub over the miz and john morrison
that bunny was pretty impressive on
night one what did you think about him
first of all bad bunny didn't have a
single box on it
it was it was you know a great sight to
see
wwe has always been known
for their work with celebrities you know
this is especially wrestling is
their their thing yeah exactly so
you know to see this be the longest drug
out celebrity story that i can remember
at least
uh he did his thing he came out he
proved himself
uh and he raised the bar and it's
something that you know i've always
dreamed of
and uh you know dinner these two was
about to have me in the craziest shape
of my life
i got i got a what 2023 before
wrestlemania is in l.a i might have to
make some calls all right so yeah buddy
in that one rich
put a pin in that one we would do no
more than that
so you'd want to do something huh yeah
but you know i gotta
you gotta yes you're in the ring yes
you're in the ring you don't wanna get
hurt
and you don't wanna hurt your opponent
but but
most of it is about getting that respect
from the fans
and i'm trying to show my fellow members
of the wwe
universe that o'shea jackson jr is about
that life
i'm about that square circle if i gotta
go
or put somebody through a table let me
do it i'll do whatever it takes
man to to raise that bar even higher so
if i have your choice that you could be
in a celebrity nba all-star game in
staples
or wwe um in sofie
what do you choose wrestlemania
come on now i gotta i gotta go to
wrestlemania what you mean yeah i mean
that's a once-in-a-lifetime one rich i
don't know i mean
i could get listen i could get the
celebrity all-star game by myself if you
just giving me a choice what to do
going to that wrestlemania bro you know
to get that moment to
you know just stand on those ropes in
front of a wrestlemania
and i understand it's different if
you're just trying to cross over a
little rel
you know what i mean so
i understand it's a different vibe but i
mean it still staples
o'shea you know i mean like your your
arena and maybe some of the nba players
are sitting there watching you play
i'm just trying to try to equate it in
any way shape or form well so far it
would still be
la so it would still be an la thing for
him right so
you know and you know how he rolls with
us
let's talk about last night's main event
edge reigns brian the big dog
came out on top what did you think about
the main event of wrestlemania last
night
uh well
he told us he was gonna do that
acknowledge him
okay so yeah paul heyman you know his
thing that he likes to say is
it's not you know it's not it's not a
prediction
it's a spoiler roman reigns is a
force in this business and this is the
roman
we've all been waiting we've wanted this
and the the beautiful thing about that
match last night
is all three of those men were never
supposed to wrestle again
yeah the other people don't know that at
a point in time
they were retired and never supposed to
be in a wrestling ring again
and now they're all three main eventing
wrestlemania and roman reigns just
showing his dominance
how could you not like roman he is the
coolest thing out there
he he should be like this and this this
this new persona head of the table
you know tribal chief it's great you
don't get that unless you're a multiple
time
champion you don't get that just out the
gate it wouldn't have worked
if that was the first thing he tried
after the shield
we wouldn't have believed it but now
this dude is a multiple wrestlemania
main event
and winner and one thing i know that has
proven himself royal rumbles
this dude has done his thing he deserves
everything he deserves the flowers that
he wears around his neck
you know shay you know one thing about
wrestling fans that drives me up the
wall and i am one so i can say it
everyone wanted john cena to go hill
right and he didn't do it
people wanted roman reigns to go hill
for years
and he didn't turn hill and i always
thought be careful what you wish for
because you just might get it and now
this man has taken that persona
he's embraced who he really is and we
talked earlier about bloodlines and
family lineage if you're running a
billion dollar corporation and you look
down the line and you see roman reigns
you know where he came from
that's the guy i'm gonna put as my top
dude
i just don't understand why the fans are
still mad you wanted him as a hill
now you got him as a hill embrace it
yeah man i don't i don't i don't get it
either i don't see how you can
how you can see everything that first of
all
story wise that he's done the uso
uh brother jay jay what's the main event
jay
yeah he he he brings it every
week for this for this this story that
they're doing about this head of the
table
and it is it's one of the best things
that wwe has got going in a
long time and roman is the centerpiece
of that
he is everything i had been awaiting him
to be
then the shield you look cool because we
hated you
and then when you were supposed to be
you can't be a menacing
looking baby face it just doesn't
it just doesn't mesh well but you make
that dude a dominant
force a beast the way that he is it's a
handy glove fit
i love it wrestlemania 37 talk right
here on the rich eisen show with o'shea
jackson jr
we just talked about some uh wwe heel
turns no
greater heel turn maybe in the history
of pop culture than anakin skywalker
so
how about you uh going to star wars uh
o'shea how about you being the new obi
wan kenobi that my entire family is
absolutely gonna watch on disney plus
when it comes out
how about that one yeah i'm uh
i'm pretty poppin dude
now is this like fight club you can't
really talk about it
or or what i mean can you talk about it
what can you talk about
about come on dude the mouse is
listening dude the mouse is listening i
can't really
i can't really speak too much on it well
i used to work for the mouse so i
understand the mouse listens but
um let then let's let's cut around the
edges here
uh if i told you growing up you'd be in
star wars you'd be acting in a star wars
um vehicle or venture that would that
how cool is that
i mean that's off the charts oh man i i
you know my family we uh
my parents took us to you know star wars
premieres
uh there was a time where empire strikes
back was
uh they like re-released it in theaters
we went to go see it then
um so it's a it's a dream come true you
know
first you know the things that that made
little kids say like you go crazy
are the lakers you know the lakers of
course
acknowledging me anytime is always great
wrestling
godzilla uh star wars and video games
and i'm getting a little bit of
acknowledgement from all sides of that
and
it's a dream come true um i'm a
it's honored to be one of the 12 black
people in space in the star wars
universe
[Music]
i'm trying to keep our legacy going no
sam jackson's one of the one one of the
the people you're referring to right so
there you go that's not a that's not a
bad group
lando billy d
i mean let's let's the handful
you know and and so um you're saying
are you saying that there is a
photograph somewhere of baby shea
cube and family with like harrison ford
on a red carpet
somewhere is that does that exist
i don't know if uh okay i don't know
might be somewhere out there
googling some some sort of yeah
hey that's that's what the internet's
for when i saw that i'm like first of
all i couldn't be more excited the
mandalorian in my household
was amazing to get three kids to
actually agree on anything and we
watched it
and we're cheering and we're high-fiving
and it was so terrific and now to see
you know obi-wan kenobi and and the cast
is getting back together from the films
and you're involved too
i couldn't be more fired up for you i
was very excited to see that
truly thank you man it's uh yeah when it
was announced i wasn't
ready like i didn't know and my phone
was blowing up and i was like oh my god
who died
oh no oh no well something is going to
be some terrible news
spoiler alert vader
is that a problem
it's definitely a dream come true to
even have
hayden uh back with you and mcgregor
right there in itself is you know
blockbuster
and personally you know depending on my
man
on the response from my man from uh for
hayden
i think it'd be really cool if we got a
vader show that'd be dope
there you guys want to throw it out
there i want to see
young darth vader i need it in my life
so hopefully i don't know i might have
to call the mouse
hey you put the plus in disney plus oh
shade let's just put it there
thank you man hey congrats on everything
going on with your career
and i appreciate you uh chopping it up
with us about wrestlemania 37 and more
appreciate it of course man you know
this is uh
you know one of my other homes i
appreciate you guys as always
everybody out there tj chris you know i
appreciate all y'all
keep doing it man yeah no we'll have you
back on when the lakers are battling the
mavs for the seventh seed so
uh we'll have people how michigan do it
how missing
don't get this man started rich no are
you owning ucla too
hold on a second are you are you
co-opting ucla
as well oh shane is that what you're
saying or is it all i'm a trojan bro i
was mad they beat michigan i picked i
picked michigan for the whole thing
no well i wouldn't it wasn't a bad
choice
but you know look ucla was terrific but
i think it was they
i think baylor would have buzz saw
anybody quite honestly you know i i
really thought
sure so uh thanks for the call oh shea
let's
truly i love having you on let's do this
again shortly appreciate it
all right tj clifford's up oh man
that's my job it's in my job tatum by
the way that's a new drop
on the show tj clippers sucked from
ocean
by the way and then that was that was
a rough week because stephen a smith is
coming bro i'm telling you i don't think
you understand it's going to be a rough
week for tj jefferson or it could be a
start making a turn 37. he has the whole
he has like five minutes of time with a
big time actor
talking about wrestlemania 37 just
trying to bring new eyes to the rich
eyes
no i understand he's getting worked up
about pith i do and then all of a sudden
just
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here